and he's right
because women are women there's lower
risk and there's higher risk but women
are women
um and again we're just brainwashed into
saying female nature is so amazing and
so special and it's like from God and
we're so smart and
not really I don't know I mean they're
smart women there's lower risk women but
they're still women and there's a reason
that in history women really weren't
believed wasn't for no reason and that's
that's the biggest you know that's what
I've learned a lot of times there is a
reason
look at history like just these
oppressive mean people but a lot of
times there's reasons that we did what
we do now does that mean everything
would work today I don't know the path
moving forward but I think the first
step is acknowledging female nature and
putting in policies that protect men
from female nature